[موسيقى]
بسب
اسمع الله
يمسيكم
بالخير
ضيوف
حح م
هلا ابرو المزين الكرام يا 100 هلا
ح
يا
طبعا فرقه العنقاء للفنون هي فرقه فلكلور
فلسطيني تاسست في غزه عام 2005 ميلادي
بجهود حفنه من الشباب الفلسطيني الواحد
الراقصين والراقصات فيها ازداد عن ال 40
راقص وراقصه بالاضافه زاد عنا نادي تدريب
الاطفال في الفلكلور الفلسطيني اصبح عددهم
120 طفل الفرقه بتقدم عروض فلكلوريه من
خلالها بتقدم لوحات ساميه بتحمل رسائل
ساميه ل العالم
الغربي ال عنقا بتشارك بمهرجان فلسطين
الدولي اللي هو بعد فتره من النسيان كانت
قطاع غزه بسبب الظروف الحصار الفني الخانق
على قطاع غزه قال الفنون اليوم راح تشارك
لوحه بعنوان زريف ها ها اللوحه را تحكي
فيها باكثر من تسع رقصات التسع رقصات راح
يصلوا لحد 45 دقيقه متواصله رح يقدموها
بين الشباب والصبايا والاشبال
[موسيقى]
والزهرات الكرامه حتقدم
اعمال مفاجاه وهي الاعمال اللي احنا ح
نقدمها هي من اعمالنا من كلماتنا والحاله
وهذا الشيء اللي بيميزنا وهذا الشيء
المفاجئ اللي احنا ح نقدمه
للجمهور
هلمو ضو
[موسيقى]
ديتنا يا ليل هل
نو
نا
[موسيقى]
s